hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta oportunidad nos
acompaña isabel allende escritora y
periodista chilena considerada como la
escritora vidad más leída del mundo de
la lengua española sus obras fueron
traducidas a más de 40 idiomas y ha
vendido más de 75 millones de ejemplares
a lo largo de todo el mundo realizamos
esta entrevista en el marco del 6
festival de colombia que como todos los
años reúne a figuras destacadas de la
literatura de las ciencias y las artes
entre otras áreas
isabel allende muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
este año el festival se da casi por
completo bajo una moda digital por
supuesto por el contexto de pandemia que
estamos viviendo hace ya casi un año
cambiaron por completo nuestros modos de
vida de vincularnos y muchas otras cosas
y subyace la idea de un nuevo mundo
verdad nuevas interpretaciones también
de este mundo y de la vida como cree
usted que afectarán y llegarán estas
nuevas miradas a la literatura
este ha sido un tiempo de reflexión en
que yo creo que nos vamos a volver a la
antigua normalidad y en este tiempo que
hemos aprendido algunas lecciones y una
de las lecciones más importantes que
hemos aprendido es que somos una sola
familia humana lo que le pasa a una
persona en una ciudad de la china nos
pasa a todos este enemigo que es el
virus no lo vamos a resolver
nacionalmente es un esfuerzo global es
una guerra de la de la humanidad contra
el virus es a esa noción de que estamos
unidos de manera irrevocable y de que
vivimos en un planeta fracking creo que
va a determinar la normalidad del futuro
y no lo vamos a ver inmediatamente pero
va a ser un efecto que se va a ir viendo
próximamente no podemos seguir viviendo
en un mundo
que no es sostenible en un mundo del
consumismo de violencia de divisiones de
odio y todo eso que va a cambiar que yo
creo que va a cambiar y yo nos vamos a
demorar pero va a cambiar se va a
reflejar en la literatura porque son los
creadores no solo la literatura sino que
cualquier forma de arte la que nos
presenta una visión de lo que puede ser
son los que van adelante con las ideas y
con las imágenes y los sueños colectivos
yo creo que la literatura no va a
reflejar también agrado ustedes de
isabel de un tiempo de cambios no
también de aprendizajes que le he
enseñado a usted la pandemia
en lo personal a mí me alejado la
enseñanza de que necesito cada vez menos
no quiero más cosas en mi vida quiero
mucho consumir mucho menos quedarme con
lo esencial
he aprendido quiénes son las verdaderas
personas que ambos los verdaderos amores
y cuánto cuánto tiempo se pierde en
cosas que uno ni siquiera valora y
aprender a decir que no a casi todo y
quedarse con lo que vale la pena y
aprendió la importancia del cariño y del
amor yo creo que no habría sobrevivido
esta pandemia solo en mi casa
afortunadamente tengo perro yo marido
ahora así que no estaba sola y eso me ha
ayudado mucho
y saber usted mantiene una tradición que
es muy conocida por todo el mundo cada 8
de enero comienza una nueva obra este
año tan particular lo hizo también
el año pasado la pandemia me ayudó a
escribir dos libros escribir este
mujeres del alma mía y había comenzado
el 8 de enero una novela que la termina
en diciembre y ya está en manos de mi
agente y este 8 de enero comencé otro
libro mira querido si no estoy
escribiendo no vuelvo vuelvo loco a todo
el mundo alrededor mío y yo misma
termino histérica la escritura me
mantiene ocupada interesada con
curiosidad y pensando o sea me mantiene
entrenando la mente ahora era 1982 no
cuando le llegó el reconocimiento
mundial con su obra la casa de los
espíritus una novela que muestra entre
muchas otras cosas como diferentes
generaciones de mujeres a lo largo del
tiempo fueron lidiando con las
restricciones de un patriarcado muy
fuerte no como ve desde hoy la novela y
sus personajes femeninos con un
movimiento feminista muy fuerte en chile
yo veo que las mujeres hemos obtenido
mucho mucho ha cambiado pero cuál es el
objetivo final de esta tremenda
revolución que es el movimiento de
liberación femenina
reemplazar el patriarcado por una
gerencia del mundo en que hombres y
mujeres tengan el mismo número crítico
en el poder en que los valores femeninos
y masculinos tengan el mismo peso en la
sociedad falta mucho para llegar ahí
pero para allá vamos y no hay que
desanimarse por el camino porque lo que
se ha avanzado en los últimos yo diría
50 años es mucho más de lo que se avanzó
200 200 años anteriores la comunicación
los medios de información y la rapidez
con que cambia el mundo han ido
acelerando el proceso pero necesitamos
más mujeres y más hombres que se
incorporen a esto porque hombres como tú
jóvenes que seguramente fueron educados
por mujeres como yo porque yo podría ser
tu mamá otra abuela
y eso también son parte de nuestro
movimiento es porque dejarlos afuera
ahora cambiando de tema las cartas han
tenido una importancia muy grande en su
vida isabel mantuvo una larga
correspondencia por ejemplo con su madre
de hecho su obra paula comenzó con
cartas a su hija no mientras se
encontraba en coma atravesando una
durísima enfermedad y es además el libro
que más cartas de lectores género que
representan las cartas en su vida y que
destacaría usted de este modo de
expresión y de comunicación
las cartas para mí comenzaron cuando
tenía como 15 años estábamos viviendo en
el líbano vino una situación política de
revolución en el líbano y mi padrastro
al inefable tío ramón nos mandó de
vuelta chile a los hijos y yo fui a dar
a la casa de mi abuelo y mi madre y mi
padrastro se fueron a turquía y ahí
comenzó la correspondencia diaria con mi
madre de las cartas demoraban a veces
seis semanas en llegar pero no importaba
porque era una conversación de sordos no
seguir escribiendo escribiendo y lo que
te volvía no era una respuesta sino otro
monólogo que de turquía es a ese hábito
lo mantuvimos con mi madre diariamente
por décadas hasta el punto de que hace
poco mi hijo decidió digitalizar las
cartas que yo tengo guardadas por años
en cajas de plástico y calculo que había
más de 24.000 cartas entre las que yo le
mandé a mi madre las que ella me mandaba
a mí que están coleccionadas ahí es toda
una vida la vida de ella y la vida mía
en esas cartas
ahora porque han sido fueron tan
importantes yo creo que es un
entrenamiento hacia la
hacia la reflexión de uno reflexiona
sobre su propia vida en esas cartas que
le van a contar a tu madre todos los
días no saca no le vas a contar lo que
hiciste de comer no le vamos a contar el
sobre si está lloviendo o no está
lloviendo son cosas mucho más interiores
entonces hay un permanente proceso de
introspección de reflexión de
comunicación y de amor porque porque él
escribe uno a ella porque uno la ama y
porque recibe de vuelta a la carta
porque llamaba es esa esa comunicación
hoy día no la tengo porque mi mamá se
murió hace dos años pero la tengo con
mis lectores lectoras sobre todo todos
los días cuando abro mi computadora que
es varias veces al día
hay un chorizo de este largo de cartas
que me llegan de un mensaje que me
llegan de mis lectoras en que me cuentan
sus vidas me cuentan sus tragedias me
piden consejos que no puedo dar porque
aunque voy al consejo poder yo pero hay
una comunicación permanente y eso a mí
me enriquece la vida y además me obliga
a pensar hablemos ahora un poco
su obra alargó pétalos de mar que está
basada en el arribo a chile de 2000
refugiados españoles que estaban
escapando de la guerra civil usted misma
vivió la emigración muchas veces a lo
largo de su vida hace varios años
estamos viendo olas de inmigrantes en
todo el mundo que son rechazados por
países que les cierran sus puertas ese
rechazo que vivieron durante la
dictadura de pinochet los refugiados
españoles y que cuenta en su novela lo
ve hoy en sistemas democráticos
hay una se calcula que hay más o menos
80 millones de refugiados en el mundo en
este momento y esos son los que han
contado hay muchos que no están contados
la mayoría son mujeres y niños y este es
un problema global que se va a ir y que
se va a ir incrementando porque con el
cambio climático van a ver las enormes
regiones del planeta que van a estar
incendiada o ind hadas o con sequías
terribles no se va a poder cultivar nada
y va a haber una inmigración
prácticamente de hambre
buscando un lugar donde puedan
sobrevivir de manera que este no es un
problema que se va a resolver alzando
muros para detener a la gente sino que
hay que encontrar soluciones globales
globales para incorporar toda esta gente
y para mejorar las condiciones por las
cuales la gente sale como refugiados que
son casi siempre guerra crimen
narcotráfico violencia de alguna clase y
hambre también pobreza la pobreza es una
terrible forma de violencia
cuál es la solución la solución no es
atajar a la persona que busca asilo
cuando ya llegó sino que mejorar las
condiciones de vida para que no tenga
que salir de su lugar de origen nadie
quiere dejar todo lo que llama atrás
para ir a un lugar donde va a ser
recibido con hostilidad sino porque está
desesperado nadie arriesga a los hijos
para eso si no es porque está
desesperado proceso lo que hay que
resolver primero cambiando en además de
tema más de un año no del estallido
social en chile que dejó violaciones a
los derechos humanos pero también un
plebiscito constitucional como analiza
usted esta coyuntura y en qué cree o
mejor dicho en qué desea que podría
derivar
bueno la nueva constitución que se
supone va a ser una constitución
democrática que salga del pueblo hacia
arriba y no impuesta por las autoridades
es como un mapa es una guía que nos
permite avanzar hacia el futuro con un
camino más o menos trazado pero eso es
eso lo que es nada más todo lo demás hay
que construirlo
una cosa es inventar una constitución y
la otra es llevarla a cabo y chile ha
pasado por una verdadera crisis de
valores
es un país donde la gente el pueblo ya
no cree en ninguna de las instituciones
no creen en el congreso
la popularidad del presidente ya no
puede ser peor y nadie cree en el
sistema judicial detestan a la policía
nadie cree en la iglesia nadie deja solo
a un niño con un cura por todos los
escándalos que han habido de manera que
está esta crisis de fe en las
instituciones es un tremendo remezón que
yo creo que nos va a servir mucho para
construir una nueva normalidad un nuevo
chile mejor
pero no hay por qué que dejar de lado
aquellas cosas que son buenas de chile
hay que preservarlas
el chile tenía una buena economía pero
próximamente mal distribuido los
recursos lo que la economía puede seguir
siendo por ese mismo camino pero los
recursos tienen que distribuirse las
oportunidades tienen que alcanzar para
todo no puede ser es que haya un 1% de
la población que tiene riqueza riqueza
como no se ve en ninguna otra parte y
hay gente que no puede comer eso no
puede ser
vamos finalizando la entrevista isabel
24 libros traducidos a más de 42 idiomas
más de 75 millones de libros vendidos
más de 60 premios a lo largo de todo el
mundo que es para usted el éxito
el éxito y sobre todo lo que te decía
el cariño de los lectores esas cartas
que recibo por centenares por miles
eso es el éxito porque los demás no se
ve o sea todo lo que todo el éxito de
los millones de libros vendidos o los
idiomas entonces pasa afuera no entra a
la vida de uno yo sigo me tienes también
mariel sigo siendo la misma persona con
los pocos amigos que tengo mi pequeña
familia nada cambia un 11 siempre sigue
siendo el mismo el éxito ocurre afuera y
si uno permite que no se te suban los
humos a la cabeza estás arruinado porque
así como viene desaparece en 24 horas
isabel allende muchísimas gracias por
esta entrevista de france 24 ha sido un
lujo tenerla en esta programación en
nuestra audiencia de la invitamos a
seguir informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france 24
punto com
[Música]